That doesn't reflect reality,
this idea of very linear, predictable careers
where there are enough promotions for everybody,
that that doesn't actually reflect people's experience.
And it also doesn't reflect people's individuality.
People want to do different things.
They don't necessarily want a career based on conformity.
They want the choice to develop
in the direction that's right for them.
- Hello, everybody.
Welcome to season four of Better at Work.
We're delighted to be back with you.
I'm Carl Quinlan.
I've got some exciting news for you.
We're now not just in your ears, but on your screens too.
That's right, Better at Work is now available
to watch on YouTube or Spotify.
Explore our conversations with some remarkable guests.
And new this season, listeners questions episodes
with my lovely co-host Annette
on the Better at Work YouTube channel and Spotify.
You can also simply keep listening
wherever you get your podcasts.
Now to kick off season four,
I sat down with a very special guest,
someone I've admired for a long time, Helen Topper.
Now Helen is co-author of the Sunday Times bestseller,
The Squiggly Career, and of course,
she's CEO of Amazing If.
Helen has helped thousands of people re-imagine their career
from climbing that traditional ladder
to something far more exciting,
full of possibility and squiggly.
But when you flip to squiggly thinking,
you don't talk about levels, you talk about learning,
you don't talk about grades, you talk about growth,
you don't talk about titles, you talk about talents,
you don't talk about plans, you talk about possibilities.
It's just, it's a much more curious and open way
of looking at your career.
What I loved about this chat
is how practical Helen's advice is
and how she takes us
into her personal career transformation journey.
She realized so many people are stuck
chasing ladders and titles,
but what really holds us back isn't the structure,
it's a lack of confidence.
That was the game-changing realization in her own career.
If you've ever felt stuck
or like someone else is actually writing your story,
this episode is for you.
This is a big one to have Helen on the show.
She's joining us here from our studios in London.
Welcome, Helen, to Better at Work.
Aw, thank you so much for having me.
I can't wait for the conversation.
It's such a long time we've been planning this.
I know, I know, I'm really looking forward to it.
Now look, we start all of our discussions
with all of our guests the same way,
which, where did it all start for you?
What happened in your early life
or along the way that drove this interest
in helping people have better careers?
Yeah, I mean, it definitely didn't start with that.
Selfishly, I think it was very, like, my career.
I think that's definitely where it started.
And I have always been very, very driven,
very, very ambitious.
And I think I saw the ladder
as, like, the ideal version of success.
And early on in my career,
I think that was, like, indicated by, like, graduate schemes.
I mean, graduate schemes are the way to go.
In careers, particularly like traditional grad schemes,
when careers look like ladders,
you start on a grad scheme.
And I like them so much, I did three back-to-back.
You were joking.
I loved it.
I loved it 'cause it was like ready-made progression.
Oh my God.
So I did this one that was, like, affiliated with my course,
which is where I ended up meeting my business partner back.
Like, this is 2001, where we kind of met each other.
2001, yeah.
Gosh, gosh.
Yeah, early, early days, we met each other there.
I did, like, a boot sort of graduate scheme,
an early version of it.
Then I went and did one at Britvic.
Then I went and did an advanced graduate scheme
at Procter & Gamble.
And then I kind of realized,
oh, I need to get a job.
I need to get a job.
But I think I saw them as a sign of success.
And, you know, that was sort of this accelerated progression
that I was looking for.
And then I hit the jobs.
And I realized then that a lot of the learning
that I was looking for didn't seem to happen every day
in a normal job.
And that these ideas of kind of wait your turn,
do your time, stay in your lane.
Like, these started to be some of the things
that I was seeing.
And I forced it quite a lot.
Like, I moved across a couple of different companies.
I really tried to force the point.
I was like, I'm not sure that this is
what a good career looks like.
And I had a degree of success in doing that.
But I think that was because I was so ambitious
and driven and so confident.
And I started to realize that other people
were feeling quite stuck in traditional structures
and they didn't have the same level of confidence
or support in navigating it as I did.
And I guess it was that sort of insight
that was shared with my friend now, business partner,
that led us to say, well, how can we help people?
What can we do?
And so that was about 2013,
where we were both sharing very similar reflections
on our careers and our experience.
And also this insight that other people were finding
the same situations but didn't have the ability
to change it themselves.
They needed some help that wasn't available.
- Well, so you saw that kind of consistent gap
that other people were having as well.
- Yeah, they would say I feel stuck
and I don't know what to do about it.
I want to do something different,
but I don't know how to make it happen.
And what also seemed to be true
is the more senior you got in a company,
the more career support you could access.
- Oh God, yes.
That is so true.
And it's almost like you want to give that
to people a bit sooner, right?
- Absolutely.
And I really don't understand why we don't do that,
why the majority of the workforce
are given the minority of the support.
It doesn't stack up to me 'cause don't you want?
- It's almost like they don't want them
to have an a-ha moment too early
'cause they wanna work 'em for a few years.
- Well, but then I kind of think,
well, if they don't have it,
then they'll probably leave to get it elsewhere
and water waste for everybody.
So we kind of had this principle
of well, let's democratize career development.
Let's not limit learning by level.
Let's make this accessible to everybody.
And that was a real guiding thought in our early days.
And it's definitely become part of our company now,
but I mean, we didn't have a company in 2013.
We just had this insight.
- You were doing still your job
and you were doing a bit of it at the weekends
and everything, right? - Yeah.
They were like running like these little evening sessions
that six people turned up to.
- But it's such a good way to do it.
You know, like, and I know we'll talk about that.
Like, you know, how do you kind of look for opportunities?
Maybe when you're in a career you don't love,
how do you actually find, I suppose, opportunities
to do things that you think you're gonna love more?
- Yeah.
- Now, for any of our listeners
that never heard of the Squeakly Career,
because we know some of our listeners in Australia
and the US, et cetera, haven't.
How would you explain, what is a Squeakly Career?
- Yeah, yeah, no, it's a really good, let's start there.
Let's start there.
So we are trying to contrast
with the idea of the ladder-like career.
And so if we start there,
the ladder-like career says that you pick a path,
you progress by going up the ladder,
you start talking about, you know, the next step.
The assumption is that success is seniority
and that's what everybody wants from work
and, you know, that promotions are possible
'cause that's all sort of the ingredients
of ladder-like careers.
Our perspective is that that doesn't reflect reality.
This idea of very linear, predictable careers
where there are enough promotions for everybody,
that that doesn't actually reflect people's experience.
And it also doesn't reflect people's individuality.
People want to do different things.
They don't necessarily want a career based on conformity.
They want the choice to develop in the direction
that's right for them.
So Squeakly Career, we believe, is a better way
of people thinking about their career.
It gives them the freedom and flexibility
to develop in different directions.
But it also, it presents to people that actually
your career is probably not going to be predictable.
You and I are going to need to develop skills
we have not got yet.
We are potentially going to do jobs
that don't even exist yet.
And if we are open to that, we'll create more opportunities.
But if we are close to that, if we're not proactive,
if we're not exploring, if we're not curious,
then actually our careers become quite vulnerable
and we don't want people to be vulnerable
in a context of change.
We want people to use that change to fuel their career
rather than mean that it sort of leaves them feeling lost.
That's not what we want.
- I love what you, I heard you say this
on another podcast recently.
You said think, I think you said think talent not titles.
And I thought it was really interesting
'cause what you're trying to get people to think about
is what are their unique talents
and actually how can you accelerate those
as opposed to thinking in,
I've got to reach this next title.
- Yeah, well, there's a lot of ladder like language
that goes along with that concept.
So you end up, if you look at careers like ladders,
you end up with words like,
or kind of a fixation on titles.
And everything has to sound similar
and a bit more senior to what I currently do.
So you get the kind of junior executive direct,
it's all in the same path, all a bit more senior.
And you end up talking about plans,
the perfect career plan.
You talk about promotions, you talk about levels,
you talk about grades.
But when you flip to squiggly thinking,
you don't talk about levels, you talk about learning,
you don't talk about grades, you talk about growth,
you don't talk about titles, you talk about talents,
you don't talk about plans, you talk about possibilities.
It's just, it's a much more curious and open way
of looking at your career.
And the language is actually a really fundamental part
'cause if you were my manager,
I'd be talking to you about my career.
And if I talked to you about the next job title I want
in Kahal's company or the next level I want to get to,
it's quite a closed conversation.
But if I talk to you about the talents I want to be known for
and the learning I want to gain so I can grow,
very different conversation.
- Yeah, it's interesting 'cause having myself worked
in large companies for too long,
there's a lot around job architecture and okay,
this is what's expected at this level here,
the core capabilities you need, et cetera.
And I do think people's brain goes to,
"Okay, I've got to do that, I've got to do a project
that's going to allow me to do X."
And sometimes they move away
from what they're actually really good at
and they lose a bit of spark I think when they do,
not everyone but some.
- Well, I think, so one of the squiggly skills we talk about
is the importance of values.
And I think, and values are what motivates and drives you.
And if you don't have an awareness of that,
I think you fall into the trap of validation.
So I think a lot of that is,
well, I need to tick that box and you kind of lose sight of,
"Is it the box I really want to tick?"
Because you just think,
"Well, I need to be successful and senior,
so I've got to tick that box."
And I'm not sure box ticking is people always
being at their best to your point.
- I totally agree.
And I didn't have this question,
but just as you were talking there,
I was thinking about men and women,
do you think they squiggle differently in terms of,
because my experience of women is that they are often
the ones who do take time out to have children, et cetera.
And then they have to come back
and almost have a different role.
I've often seen it in big corporates
where they leave a job as a manager, they come back in.
It's like, "Oh, actually you want to work three days a week.
You can't go back to be a manager.
You're going to have to come back in as a different role."
Whereas men, if they take paternity leave,
it's usually four weeks, et cetera,
they're back into their normal job.
That was just as coming in on the train thinking,
"Do you see a difference in how they squiggle?"
- There's actually some, just broadly,
some interesting differences that we kind of see
with gender on the skills, on the career moments,
and also gender on proactive engagement in this.
So I can share what we see.
We see women more proactively engaging
in learning about their career.
So picking up squiggly career, for example.
So when I go into a company, everyone engages equally,
but outside of the company bringing us in,
I would say we see more women.
I look at the demographics of our podcast, for example,
I see more women.
So that, I see kind of a slightly more interest
in proactivity from women on that side,
even though I think this is important for everybody.
In terms of sort of moments that matter,
I think particularly for women,
you mentioned kind of childcare, for example,
there's a definite pivot point for women
where they have slightly different pressures in their career,
which lead them to reconsider what they want from work.
I think there seems to be more of those pivotal moments.
So we definitely see, I'm interested in career change,
I don't know how to do it.
I want to do something different,
but I have some constraints on me now
because I've got childcare.
So it does seem to be that kind of point.
I think it's interesting when people find squiggly.
People will often come to me at an event
and they'll be like, oh, you really helped me when?
And so there are sort of moments at a time
when people get made redundant,
when people have a significant career change,
where people have made a bad move
and they think, oh, you really helped me when,
it seems to be, that seems to be where a lot of people find it.
- Yeah, we get similar.
It's sometimes when people are reaching
a milestone birthday, like 40 or 50,
they go, oh, I need to have a little bit of a look
at where I'm at in my career.
But no, I find as well,
I've seen in some cases with women,
they are able to pivot better than men
because they've had to,
oh, well, actually I went on maternity leave four years ago
and I came back into a different role.
I didn't think I loved marketing,
but actually the role that was available was in marketing.
It's been brilliant.
And I've learned all these new skills,
which I think is a great benefit for people
and particularly women when that happens.
I do see on the other side,
sometimes women get disgruntled when they come back
and they're like,
they probably are still in that ladder-like mindset of like,
oh, I've gone back down the ladder now.
I used to often hear that from having two children.
I was here, my peer has gone two wrongs above me, right?
- Well, that was the third area I was gonna say.
So I see that sort of productivity difference there.
I definitely see the moments that matter.
There are some different moments that matter.
And the third is the skills that people,
there are five skills that we think are important
for people succeeding in a squiggly career.
One of them is confidence.
And I see some specific confidence gremlins
resonate more with women.
So the imposter one, I see a lot,
which is kind of a fear of being found out
is how we frame it.
Comparison resonates a lot and also likability.
Those three, when I kind of look across different audiences
for women, those gremlins are bigger.
- Yeah, I completely agree.
We'll touch on some of those gremlins as well.
You know, I was thinking about my own experience as well.
And Harrison who's here today was asking me
about some of the things that have happened in my career
that might resonate with people on social media.
And I actually did suffer a burnout twice in my career.
And one time was because of this focus on the career ladder,
you know, like really pushing, working crazy hours,
doing work that really I didn't really love,
but I was in the kind of machine almost,
if you like that kind of thing.
- I saw that post on social media.
I thought it was brilliant.
- Yeah, and I thought it was important to share that,
but it kind of links to what you guys do
and talk about a lot in Squeakly Career
is that this kind of concept of the ladder
can be quite stressful, right?
And the question I put down here is, you know,
do you think that some people come to Squeakly?
And I think you kind of mentioned it there
at moments where they're burnt out as well.
- Yeah, I think they come because they're lost.
I think they come because what they're doing
doesn't feel right to them anymore.
But I mean, I also have people that come to Squeakly
because they're like really ambitious.
Like they're not lost.
They're like, they're hungry.
But what they've realized is that the traditional route
to success isn't gonna do it for them.
So they are definitely more in,
I am excited about my career.
I love what I do.
I just wanna do more.
And I know I need to think a bit more creatively
about how to do that because I don't want to wait
to get promoted.
I want to do more now.
So I think it's, for us, for Squeakly,
we want Squeakly to be kind of as universal
as possible for people.
But there are definitely different motivations.
- Oh, I mean, your stuff, it applies.
And so, I mean, we'll talk about the five skills.
They're just so relevant for people
in all different phases of their career.
You just got me thinking there as well
as you were talking about careers.
It's my partner says to me,
I said I was still ambitious for my career.
I stepped out of one job.
And he said to me, you shouldn't be ambitious
for your career.
You should be ambitious for your life,
which is a really interesting.
Oh, actually, you know my partner, of course,
'cause you've done some work with them.
I just thought of that.
But yeah, it's interesting
because I think Squeakly Careers is a little bit
about working on your values,
thinking about what kind of a life do you want?
It's not necessarily about this ladder,
this career ladder.
- I always think it's really important.
Sometimes I talk to people about what I do.
And obviously I'm very passionate like you.
I'm very passionate about what I do.
And they'll go--
- I think you're more passionate than me.
- I mean, I'm upset.
But they'll say to me, oh, Helen, it's only work.
And I kind of get the point that they're making,
but then I do think your work.
So in your life, the thing that you do most
with your entire hours of your life is sleep.
So I can't help anyone with that.
But the thing that you do next
with the most hours of your life is work.
And so I think work is really important.
I think it's important to your identity.
I think if you are happy at work,
that has ripples on people
that you spend time with outside of work.
And so I think work is, I think it matters.
- So I'm with you.
That's why I started a podcast three years ago.
It's like when work's not good, life's not good.
We had Margaret Heffernan on the podcast.
- I love Margaret.
- I love her.
And she made a great point.
I said to her, when work's not good, life's not good.
And she said to me, you know what, Colin?
It's not just life's not good for you.
It's for all the people around you.
It's for your wife, your husband, your kids.
So it is very important.
That's why I think you've got the passion for it.
I have the passion for it.
And that's why I wanted to get you on
because I think so many people
are still a little bit stuck at times.
And sometimes they have the energy.
They wanna do something to fulfill themselves more.
Let's talk about the skills.
Because the five core skills, which I love,
values, strengths, confidence, community, possibilities.
So good.
Let's just, we'll start, we won't go through all of them,
but let's start with, I love,
I kind of flipped them around 'cause I like skill,
I've put values as skill one.
I really like-
- Oh my gosh, I'm so glad you've done that.
Okay, secret debate.
I'm gonna let you into a little squiggly secret here.
Okay, so-
- He's writing it down.
- In the book, in the book, strengths comes first.
- Yes, it does, yes.
- This was a big debate between me and my business partner
because I believe values should come first.
It's so interesting that you've done that.
- So I think the same, to be honest.
Annette, hello Annette, who does the show.
We had similar discussions in some of the content
we were putting together about,
should self-awareness come first?
And actually, we both landed, yes, it should come first.
And when I read through your book, I was like,
oh, I feel like values to me in my brain is the place to start.
- So I'll tell you the rationale,
and I'll tell you the naughty thing that I do together.
So my business partner's rationale, which I do buy,
is that strengths is a little bit easier,
perhaps to get started with.
Whereas, you know, values, you do have to,
you're diving quite deep if you want that to be meaningful.
So she's like, let's ease people in,
we'll start with strengths.
But my little naughty thing that I do
is every company that I go into,
I start with values, every company.
- Oh my God, and I flipped.
She actually has my questions everywhere,
because I had to send them to Helen,
'cause my iPad, I forgot it.
So yeah, I flipped it, I was like--
- I hope my business partner doesn't hear this,
should be so crossed on me.
- Yes, don't let her hear it.
But what I think is great with the values big,
you know, the book stresses the importance
of understanding your core values,
aligning your career choices with them.
And I love, there's a quote in the book,
reflection helps you align your career path
with what truly matters to you.
Now, I had a lady on the show,
and we talked a lot about values, called Aisha Basel.
I think I mentioned to her separately, she's brilliant.
And I'll ask you a question, linked to values,
who's your hero and why?
- Oh, my nan.
- And why would that be?
- Because she is, she has been through some tough things,
everything from, I don't know, being evacuated in a war
to my father dying, so I think when I was 11,
so losing her son, and then she's been on her own
for a very long time, and she is just resilient,
she's positive, and she is relevant.
So I can have a conversation with my 96 year old nan
about anything, and she's no judgment, she's amazing.
- So resilient, positive, I mean, and that's you.
So the reason that Aisha said you ask people that question
is you get a really clear sense of their values very quickly,
as opposed to asking them, you know, write these down,
et cetera, et cetera.
But I always like you start with the values,
because even when I interview people,
I'm interviewing nannies at the moment,
our lovely nanny is pregnant.
And some of the nannies I think are like, what the hell?
I asked a nanny on Zoom yesterday, I said,
so who's your hero?
She was like, and I said, and why?
Because I do think it gives you a good sense
of someone's values.
So I love that you guys had values in here,
and good, and nann is still alive.
- She is, she's amazing.
Thank you for letting me give Joyce a little shout out.
- Joyce, I hope she'll listen in now.
Now, and then you've got, I then went through it,
identifying my strengths next.
- Okay, yeah.
- And I loved, what I loved in it was,
and I've got a little picture of it here,
I took a picture of it.
You have this career graph, which I loved.
I was on that yesterday, looking at it on your website.
And it's great because it kind of gives you this,
you reflect on your career, and step one is,
you plot your career highs and lows,
starting at the beginning of your career up to today.
And then step two is, what do your career highs have
in common, and what can I learn from my career lows?
Which I thought, it's just such a clever way
to think about your strengths.
- I love doing this exercise.
This isn't even better if you do it with somebody else.
So I could sit down with you for 20 minutes.
You would talk about your highs and lows,
and you would just reflect.
And I think people just quite like reflecting
on their career, like going through it.
And as I'm listening to you,
all I'm doing is writing down the words that you're saying.
And the words that you say, also the way that you say them,
'cause sometimes you'll go, "Oh, I hated that job."
And you're, "Oh, your head will go here."
And sometimes you'll be like, "Oh, I loved it."
And you'll lean in.
So I kind of put like little marks when people,
based on how they're doing it.
And I'm just collecting clues,
the words you say more than once, the way that you say them.
And after 20 minutes, you're like, "And now I'm here."
I go, "Well, here's what I heard."
And it's not my job to say these are your values,
'cause that's your choice.
But I have subtly collected some data for your development
based on you sharing your story.
And that might be, you said the word connection five times.
And most of the time people don't know
because you've been in your story.
And I have been listening.
It's actually also a very good way of practicing listening.
So it kind of works for both people.
- I have to say, I love it.
I think it's a really smart way of doing it.
And I reflected myself on this yesterday.
And I thought, okay, when were the times that I,
when was the lows?
I worked with one particular person who,
her boss said to me, "Why don't you like working with her?"
And I said, "Look, she stifles my entrepreneurial spirit."
And I wrote that down yesterday.
I thought, "Okay, I don't enjoy working for people
who are micromanagers because I'm quite entrepreneurial."
And that was one of the skills that was really useful
in big organizations.
They liked that I was entrepreneurial.
I'd go, "Okay, let's see what's a different way
we could do this.
What's Apple doing?"
Oh, they'd be like, "We're a bank."
I don't care.
There's things we can learn.
But if I work for someone who's really like process,
like robot, like doesn't work for me.
And I think this is a great exercise for people
because sometimes it mightn't be the job.
It might be the person you're working for.
There's so many things that drive the highs and lows.
- It's quite cathartic.
'Cause you're like, "Oh, that job was awful."
- Totally. - I've done that.
- But Helen, I think what happens as well is people in their,
I particularly see people in their late 30s, early 40s,
they are really all about who they're gonna work for.
I've heard it from so many people in big banks,
in big organizations.
They say to me like, "I'm done.
I now, I decide, I meet the person.
I need to see that I can enjoy working with them."
It's interesting.
You don't see that in the 20s and maybe 30s,
but certainly late 30s, 40s, I get that.
I'm going off little data points I pick up myself,
but people get very particular about who they work for.
- They do though.
I would fly a little flag and say,
just be a bit aware of like the cult of a manager.
You know, 'cause I have definitely known people,
my business partner that's actually,
she moved to a company based on the manager,
only to find out that within like the first month,
the manager moved on.
- Oh God, yeah, that's not good.
Yeah, so I do think that whilst it is a really important
consideration, I would recommend that people
try to get a sense of the culture of the company,
a bit of exposure to the team,
so that it's not a decision based on one person.
- Totally, no, I'm with you on that.
I'm with you on that, but the exercise is so good.
It's great to kind of go, okay, look,
I was lit up when I did this type of work
or where I was given the reign to come up with a new way
of working or whatever it is.
Like that for me is great.
You never, I know for me, you don't give me a job
where they say, the boss says,
just keep it running as it is exactly,
don't change a thing, you know.
I like, I'm running out the door ASAP.
Now you touched a minute ago on these confidence gremlins,
which is skill three, which is managing self-doubt.
Now, when I read the book again,
I thought Sarah was really kind with the way she shared
in the book, you know, her fear of conflict as well,
which was really interesting.
She, if I remember correctly, she was in these meetings
where she felt there was a lot of conflict happening
and she was walked out with one of her colleagues
and she was ranting to him about it.
And she said, oh, if conflict was out of 10, that was eight.
And he was like, well, it was like a two.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it was interesting because, you know,
I thought it was really good the way she shared it.
And in the book, I love the way you've got
these little exercises people can do
to think about what would,
what are some of the confidence gremlins they might have?
- Yeah.
- But great, I mean, you said earlier,
a lot of women have this confidence gremlins.
- I think the thing with confidence gremlins,
everybody has them.
That what we do see is that, you know,
different people have different gremlins.
And it has been unintentionally the skill
that we have ended up sort of spending the most time on.
So we wrote about it in this weekly query.
We wrote about it in "You Coach You".
We then wrote another book called
"How to Know and Cage Your Confidence Gremlins".
And the reason is I think it is the biggest thing
that holds people back.
And I've come to the conclusion really
that with all the stuff that we do,
confidence is the difference between knowing and doing.
So people can know what their values are
and they can know what strengths they want to stand out.
But whether they actually take any action
is very often as a result of,
is there a gremlin getting in my way?
Am I worried that if I do have that conversation with you,
you might not like me?
Or am I worried that if I take that risk, I might fail?
Or am I worried that I'm too old to start again
in a different career?
And these gremlins that are these voices in our heads,
these sort of negative narratives
that are really critics massively in control
holds so many people back.
And it doesn't matter how senior they are.
It doesn't matter what country they're in.
Like we see gremlins everywhere.
And we just need to start talking about them
so they're in the spotlight and less in control.
- I loved it and I thought you did that very smart
in the book, how you can help people with it.
I also loved, you just reminded me,
at the start of the book, you said,
no one cares about your career as much as you do.
Which I think kind of links to the confidence gremlins
going, hey, you know what?
You might be 50, you mightn't have done
that type of work before, but who cares?
Go try it.
You know, it's great that you're giving people
that confidence to go and try something new.
- I think that is probably the most common bit of feedback
I've generally had about squiggly career
is that it gives people permission.
It's given them like a language to talk about their career.
People have even said they'll take the book
and say, this is my career.
You know, it sort of justifies.
I don't want to be a ladder-like person.
I want to be somebody who is individual.
And this concept of the squiggly career
kind of gives me a bit of permission too.
And I really like that squiggly career just in of itself
is giving people a little bit more confidence.
You've got to, we need to work with the gremlins too.
But if it's a little bit of a boost to someone's belief
that this validates something they want to do
that they haven't felt comfortable talking about,
like I'm very happy that squiggly can do that for them.
- I think you guys have done a great job
because here in the UK, I mean, I don't know anyone
that doesn't know of squiggly careers.
And I do think- - I think there'll be a few,
but we'll get there, we'll get there.
- People love it because I agree with you.
I think it gives people a bit of a, they stand taller
and they go, you know what?
I could do this too, you know?
- Yes, yeah.
- I don't need to be climbing up some ladder
that I really, it's not going to be for me.
- Yeah.
- The other skills you've got in there are,
and we'll reference the book on the show notes, et cetera,
but you've got building supportive networks and communities.
I really love that.
I love that you say to the book,
networking is about building relationships,
not just connections.
I love that because a lot of people,
they just want the connection, but-
- Well, I think, I don't know they want them.
They just think that that's what success looks like.
The more people I know, the better my network.
- Yes.
- Whereas we have this idea
that really it's about people helping people,
that it's the thing that's going to build
the best relationships is where you help people.
And actually that idea of people helping people
is quite useful psychologically.
Because even if you have someone who goes,
I hate networking, I hate it, I'm out.
People do like helping people,
like it's a human trait to want to help people.
And it actually makes you feel good when you do it.
But then Adam Grant is amazing research on this.
What he shows is that give us get more back.
So if you start with how can I be helpful,
sort of an easier place for your brain
to start building relationship in,
and then the payoff is that that results in reciprocity.
So people want to help you over time anyway.
- I completely agree.
I mean, I get a dopamine hit out of helping people.
- Me too.
- My trainer at the gym always says to me,
he goes like, I don't understand why you just like,
if someone, if he was to say to me,
I'm going to take my girlfriend out to a restaurant,
by the end of the session,
I've given him three places to go
and do not go to that place and blah, blah, blah.
And I don't know what it's like, but I get a real,
and then I love when he tells me, I took her here.
So I agree with what you said.
- It feels good, you feel useful, you're sharing.
And I think, oh gosh, imagine companies
where it's not based on people competing with people,
which is what the ladder leads to,
is people helping people.
Like it's just better.
- It's so much better.
And then the final skill you've got
is exploring future possibilities.
And I love that, the book encourages readers
to keep an open mind about future opportunities
and be proactive.
And I love the whole thing that like sideways,
moves can lead to the most unexpected
and fulfilling opportunities.
That is so true.
- Yeah.
And there are more, there are just more sideways moves.
I think if up is the only way you start to stall,
because they're just, you end up waiting for things
and waiting for people to move on.
But if you look sideways,
or you look at project opportunities,
or even you think, well, what if I went back
to something I did before?
'Cause maybe I'm a different person now.
Like I could go back to companies I've worked in before.
I could go back to functions I've worked in before.
But when you look at careers like ladders,
going back is bad.
When you look at careers like Squiggly,
going back is just a different direction you could develop it.
It's not, we kind of want to be neutral
about like, where are you going to learn the most?
Where are you going to be able to stretch your strengths
in interesting ways?
Like whether it's up, back, sideways, something different.
That's almost neutral, just consider the possibility.
- Absolutely, and I know McKinsey had put out something
a few months ago on the fact that actually
sometimes these sideways moves can give you even more.
I actually thought of you, I was like, oh my gosh,
that's like so aligned with Squiggly, right?
You know, in that actually,
it's sometimes not about a pay rise, et cetera.
You talk to people that have done a sideways move,
they get even more out of it.
- Yes, well, they get more opportunity.
And also the research shows that it can lead to more pay.
So there's this assumption that, well,
if I want to be paid more than I need to get promoted,
therefore that's the only possibility I'll consider.
But if you're waiting for a long time,
you might be better to stretch your sense in a sideways move
and build better relationships in a different area.
And that increases sort of your career capital.
And it's shown that those people
then get paid more over time.
So we just need to think slightly differently about,
I guess, what we have been told
that success sort of looks like.
- I completely agree.
And, you know, they're the five, which I absolutely love.
And just, I was thinking about linking to that skill five,
which is explore future opportunities,
because your early career was in marketing.
- Yeah.
- And, you know, how do you think that skill in marketing
has helped you pivot into this kind of career space
that you're in now?
- Yeah, it's an interesting question.
I think, I guess I want to help as many people as possible
succeed in squiggly careers.
And I think marketing is a skill
that helps you create connection,
get messages out in the world,
build a brand that resonates.
And so all the things that I learned in marketing
have helped me to scale and grow my business, definitely.
And, you know, I love marketing.
I still get to do lots of marketing now.
I get to think about how do we create squiggly career
campaigns and how do we build communities
on different platforms?
And, you know, all of our marketing skills
are brought into what I do today.
I don't have the job of like the title of marketing anymore,
but the talent is very much present in the work that I do.
- I mean, you guys kill it because Annette and I
and Phoebe and our little small team,
we always look at you guys as the kind of, wow,
those guys have built a brilliant brand,
marketed it so well.
You know, honestly, I can see your skills.
- And we've got two of us as well.
I mean, you've got two, we both worked in marketing.
- Oh, wow, so Sarah worked in marketing as well.
- Yeah, we both worked in marketing
in slightly different kind of parts of marketing.
So I did more insight, innovation.
Sarah did more sort of brand marketing.
So tone of always.
So we kind of have that passion and past experience
that we get to, you know, we get to play with.
It's brilliant.
- I tell you, the stuff is,
if anyone listening has not gone on amazing air
for or seen the resources that you guys give a lot
of resources for free.
- Well, it's back to democratizing development.
- Yeah, it's brilliant.
- And also to be honest, we have so many ideas
that we can't, it's just giving things away
that are useful, or useful is one of our values.
It just works for us.
And I think what we have realized
is helping back to people helping people,
the more people we help with squiggly careers.
So the more useful resources we create for people,
the more communities and campaigns we create,
the more people advocate for squiggly.
So, you know, that's not why we do it,
but that is the result of us putting work out
into the world is that people identify with it
and they want it to succeed.
So we just have ideas all the time.
I just can't, I can't stop creating.
- It's just like in my DNA to do it.
- It's such a good skill set to have, you know.
And the other thing I was thinking about
is because we talked about you go into companies as well.
And when I first saw this, I mean,
it might've been two, three years ago,
I discovered that you guys were going into companies.
I was like, what?
I'm surprised companies are bringing them in
to advertise squiggly careers
because won't they lose their best people or,
and then I discovered a bit more,
but actually tell us why do companies
bring you in now more and more
to share squiggly careers with all their people?
- Well, what our aim is to help people squiggle and stay.
That's the aim.
So we want people to own their squiggly career
and we want companies to create an environment
where they can squiggle and stay.
So they don't get stuck in a silo.
We want them to have possibilities in the company.
So when we work with a company,
we work across sort of three different areas.
So the first is,
does the individual have the skills to succeed
in their squiggly career?
Which is what we talked about.
Do they know those things?
The second is, do they have the support
to make that possible?
That is largely in the form of a conversation
they might have with a manager.
So can a manager create squiggly career conversations,
learning cultures in a team?
Do they have frequent feedback
that helps people grow and develop?
Like there's lots of ways in which managers support
and enable people squiggly careers.
And then the third area is a structure.
Do we have structures where people can squiggle and stay?
Or do we just lose people
'cause they're stuck in a silo?
And so the companies that most successfully adopt
squiggly careers work on skills, support and structures.
They're working across those.
And it isn't, not every company we work with
is able to do that yet.
They might start with skills
and they're building a bit of momentum
and we'll get to the next bit.
But that really is where we make the biggest difference.
- I think it's great because I think a lot of companies
are realizing that people are going to leave
if they don't see opportunities in different areas
or something that's gonna play more to their talents.
I think it's really smart of companies to do it.
- Well, we did some kind of research around this,
around squiggle and stay.
And there were sort of three reasons
why people find it easier to leave
and develop their career outside of their company
than stay and do it inside the company.
And then the three reasons are one, a lack of awareness.
So I can't see what I can be.
I know I wanna develop in the company,
but I can't see outside of marketing.
I don't know what I can do.
But if I look on LinkedIn, there's lots of jobs there.
I'll just apply for that.
So the first is you've got to give people greater awareness
of the opportunities in an organization
where their talents could take them to a job,
not just their titles.
And the second is access.
So we make it very hard for people to get to new jobs.
So you've got to be here for two and a half years.
You've got to go through 10 interviews.
You've got to have this rating.
And then you go, well, I'll just apply for that job.
I don't have to do any of those things.
I know that I could do it and I'll go there.
So we need to make it easier.
We kind of say like try before you apply.
How can you spend a week working in that team
or get some exposure on a project,
like help people to try before they apply
and make access easier?
And then the third reason is advocacy.
So even if I can see what I can be
and I've sort of tried it and I know I want to apply,
I might need somebody to speak up for me and say,
well, I know Helen's not worked in procurement,
but I have seen that she's really commercial.
I've seen that with her work in marketing
and I think we should give her a chance
or give her the opportunity.
If you can crack awareness, access and advocacy,
people will stay.
But most people aren't trying to sort of cracking
those things and so people just,
it's just easy for me to look somewhere else and leave.
- And that's really sad
'cause I think then organizations do lose
some amazing people. - Absolutely.
- And I saw some great stats on your website,
like people starting work today
will have twice as many jobs over their careers
compared to 15 years ago.
And I also saw nearly 50% of people say
they would leave an organization
where they can't progress in some way.
- Yeah, I think people want to progress.
I think we did this really fun exercise
in some of our sessions
where we call that progression bingo.
And so obviously when you're looking at careers
like a ladder, the only way you progress is getting promoted.
Our kind of premises and squiggly careers,
there's lots of ways you can progress.
So we get everyone to basically fill out the bingo card
while all the ways in which you can progress
and they'll talk about, oh, I could shadow someone,
I could go on a succumbent,
I could work on a project, loads of ways.
And then, and obviously promotion is one of those ways.
And then we ask people, this is a bit that I really love,
what do you want to do most now?
And hardly anyone ever says promotion.
They go, actually, I'd quite like to do a squiggly succumbent.
I'd quite like to go spend nine months in a different role
and just see what it's like,
or I'd like to go just do 50/50.
I'd like to do a bit of a job share.
I'd like to do 50% of my time there.
And it's like, well, let's get a bit more creative
with what career development can look like.
And people want to progress.
They've only been given promotion as the way of doing it.
- I completely agree.
And I used to see sometimes in big organizations,
managers think they own the people in the team.
And I used to say to my peers,
like, we don't own these people.
You know, like, Helen is really good at that.
I am going to allow her to have a succumbent over there
because I think that's great for the organization.
But I think sometimes people get a bit territorial,
even on their people.
They don't want, they go, well, I invested them.
I brought them in.
I don't want them going off doing something that,
you know, I didn't have to go and hire another person.
- Yeah, I think metrics don't help this.
So we have created lots of structures
where the metrics that managers are measured against
detract from them,
letting people go and develop in different directions.
'Cause they go, well, you're such a strong performer.
I need you to stay in my team
because your performance determines my performance.
And therefore, like, you're not going anywhere.
And you get this kind of talent hoarding thing
that happens. - Totally.
- Whereas if we had some mobility metrics,
so if there were manager metrics
that were more about how many people have moved
into other areas in the business from your team,
how many people who have done
what we call a squiggly safari,
where they'll have spent time in different teams,
if we had some more mobility metrics,
I think there might be a greater appetite for managers
to, you know, positively support some of these things.
- I agree, I agree.
And because sometimes some of the other metrics you have is,
you know, managers get very worried
if people are not staying in their team for a long time,
right, like, or-- - What does it say about me?
- Got high turnover in the team, whatever.
So I agree.
I think there's a little bit of work to do around that
in big organizations.
Now, we're on to our final few questions.
Is there anything happening in the world of careers right now
that's really exciting you?
- Oh, that's a lovely, that's a lovely question.
What's exciting me in the world?
I think I'm just, I think one of the most exciting things,
and everyone's talking about AI.
So it's not AI specifically,
but it's just this recognition of
that skills need to be updated.
Like, I feel like skills being in a boardroom conversation
is, that is exciting to me, like, that people are saying,
you know, what's the skill status in our organization?
What new skills do we want to develop?
Where have we got skill gaps?
Like, I just think this is becoming
a much more significant conversation.
And as somebody who is very, very passionate
about learning at work, like, I care about careers
and I care about learning at work,
I feel like they are becoming a bit more significant
in very senior discussions.
And I am all, I am all for that.
- I'm so with you.
I think the same.
Skills, it's like at the table for once.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Similar for me, I'm very passionate about leadership
and leadership is now being discussed a lot, right?
You know, how can we have better leaders?
How do we set them up for success, et cetera?
So we're getting a lot of calls
about they helped me build a program, helped me do this.
I'm like, oh my God, what's happening?
- Yeah, yeah, it's brilliant.
- So it's exciting, right?
- Yeah, it's really exciting.
- Now we ask all of our guests these final three questions.
What's the smallest possible change you think
our listeners could do to have an impact
and a better day at work tomorrow?
- I think the smallest things they could do
is to start reflecting on their,
what we call your very small successes
or what you do well at work.
And the reason to do this is, you know,
I said that confidence gremlins are getting
in most people's way.
So that's where you're kind of be telling yourself
and kind of negative story about what you're doing.
I think if we start to kind of just say
at the end of the day, what did I do well today?
What did I do well today?
Not only are you likely to start spotting some strengths
of like, hmm, I did that well because I used that skill.
I think you also start in a small but cumulative way
to build yourself belief.
So what did I do well today?
I think is a useful reflection.
- Love that, okay, I'm gonna try that tonight.
I did not do well with bringing my iPad today
to this interview.
So I had to borrow Helen's one.
- People helping people.
Can you share with our listeners something you learned
or experienced at work that unexpectedly
made your whole life better?
- Oh, I mean, my business partner.
I learned my business partner,
but what I specifically learned
and it has made my whole work and my life better
is she is my opposite in every way.
She is an introvert, I'm an extrovert.
She is very thoughtful and reflective.
I'm all about action.
And the compliments of people who are your opposite
I think can be amazing.
Like we run a better business because of our differences.
And I think it is very easy to work with people
who are similar to you that you feel comfortable with.
But sometimes those points of difference
are what makes you better.
And I'm definitely better because of her.
- I love that, I love that, I hope she's listened.
- To this bit, not the first bit.
- Exactly, yeah, not the first bit about the values.
We finish all interviews with this question.
Can you recall, Helen, the best advice you received
that you think makes you better at work?
- I can recall the advice,
but I cannot recall where it came from,
but it goes through my head almost every day.
And the advice is to run your own race.
And I find that stops me ever needing to compete or compare.
It just, it helps me go, well, you know, use your values.
If you're running your own race,
you're using your values to run that race.
And you can define your own measures of success.
And it just keeps me on my own path at my own pace,
not trying to, you know, worry about other people.
- I love that, I love that.
Thank you so much. - Oh, thank you.
- I can't believe we've had you on.
And I know my lovely co-host,
Annette's gonna be so excited to hear this as well.
- Oh, hello, Annette.
- She is a huge fan of yours.
And for anyone that wants more information
on quickly careers, you can go to amazingif.com,
where you'll find lots of practical tools and advice.
Plus, I'd love to give a little plug
to the Squiggly Career Video Book.
- Ah, thank you. - Which is now live
on litvideobooks.com.
- Yeah, they have loads, loads of,
they've basically taken the concept of a book,
turned it into a video and it's quick and easy.
They have loads of them. - It's so good, it's so good.
So it really does bring the Squiggly Career to life.
And Helen and Sarah, they talk through insights
and important exercises within the video as well.
And finally, do follow the amazing Helen on LinkedIn.
- Oh, thank you so much. - Thank you.
- Really appreciate it. - Thank you so much, everybody.
- Whoa, I absolutely love that chat.
I hope you did too.
And a huge thank you to Helen Topper.
Now, do pick up a copy of Squiggly Career
at all good bookshops and make sure you check out
the Squiggly Career podcast too.
And you might've heard it,
she's got a new book on the way, Helen.
So give her a follow on LinkedIn
and you'll hear all about the release date for that.
Now, back to our new episodes.
We have a brand new listeners question episode
coming next Thursday.
I'll be answering all your career-related questions
with Annette.
So do drop them in the comments below
or head on over to betteratwork.net/contactus.
As always, we will also be giving you the key takeaways
from my chat with Helen because we know Annette.
No one does takeaways like Annette,
so I know you're all gonna be delighted
to hear those next Thursday.
Plus, I'm super excited about our next guest,
organizational psychologist, Dr. Tasha Yorick.
She's back on the show talking
about her new book, Shatterproof.
You can't miss it.
- When you grit gaslight yourself,
you say things like,
this isn't the hardest thing I've been through.
Why am I falling apart?
Other people have it way worse than me
and they seem to be fine.
Why can't I just suck it up and deal?
But what we don't know is we are human beings
who have a limited amount of resilience.
And just because we got through everything
we got through in the past and we're here,
doesn't mean that we might not reach
that ceiling at some point.
- You won't want to miss Tasha,
so make sure you hit subscribe
if you're watching on YouTube
or listening on your podcast app.
Thanks for listening.
I'm Kyle Quinlan and this has been Better At Work.
(upbeat music)